apartamentos hospitales y edificios de
oficinas
los sitios civiles en ucrania han sido
objetivo de incesantes ataques de al
kremlin como esta escuela bombardeada en
el este del país el pasado sábado
ayer en el pueblo a bibliográfica en la
región de lugansk una bomba rusa mató a
60 civiles se estaban refugiando el
bombardeo en el edificio de una escuela
ordinaria que fue atacada por la
aviación rusa en el recital ni siquiera
las infraestructuras esenciales como
hospitales se han librado de los
bombardeos del kremlin el 9 de marzo las
fuerzas rusas atacaron este centro
materno infantil en mariupol durante un
alto el fuego reduciendo sus paredes las
compras doble 8 snow verified lado ms ha
verificado yo a 200 ataques contra
instalaciones sanitarias en ucrania
desde el inicio de la guerra estos
ataques deben cesar los centros
sanitarios nunca deben ser un objetivo
aunque sneijder
targets desde entonces las fuerzas rusas
han atacado de forma recurrente las
zonas civiles el 16 de marzo los ataques
aéreos cayeron sobre los ucranianos en
las calles de terni hiv mientras hacían
una fila para comprar pan ese mismo día
en mariupol una bomba destruyó un teatro
que albergaba a miles de personas que
buscaban refugio el último informe
oficial apunta a más de 600 víctimas en
las afueras de kiev una escena de máximo
desprecio por la vida de los civiles una
masacre en la ciudad de buzzi que dejó
más de 400 cadáveres según el informe
provisional